devriez-vous répondre au quiz sur
Facebook qui vous demande à quelle
princesse disney vous ressemblez le plus
quel serait votre nom si vous appartenez
à la royauté ou encore à quel endroit
avez-vous plus de chances de trouver
l'amour vous vous dites que ces quiz
sont drôles et plutôt inoffensifs aucun
nom derrière ces questions anodines il y
a peut-être des gens malveillants qui
veulent vous informations personnelles
en dévoilant le nom de votre animal de
compagnie la ville de votre enfance
votre couleur préférée ou votre chiffre
chanceux vous répondez à des questions
qui ressemblent drôlement aux questions
de sécurité des sites bancaires par
exemple et d'un quiz à l'autre tous ces
morceaux permettront d’assembler le
casse-tête de votre identité certains
jeux questionnaires vous demandent même
votre adresse courriel pour vous envoyer
vos résultats bonjour le hameçonnage que
ce soit par un lien qui vous mène vers
une autre page ou une publication qui
vous demande de laisser une réponse en
commentaire avant d'y répondre
posez-vous la question est-ce vraiment
nécessaire de savoir si vous a plu une
Moana ou une Elsa si vous avez répondu
non vous avez gagné passez le mot